okay let's uh continue
uh we have a french player fairly high
rated
don't know who this is um
yeah it's a three minute game so
slightly
slightly less yapping this time
so in insists on allowing the grim felt
well if you insist then i shall oblige
oblige so this is oh
that is a mouse slip
and uh quite an unfortunate one
c5 obviously was the attempt uh
intention
um yeah so here we have it
just a grunfeld temple down
uh not ideal not ideal at all
what should i do okay i'll do
i'll try bishop g4
knight c6 there d5 was probably strong
knight a5
bishop moves i can take on c3 but
with that awful knight on a5
the french knight as they like to to
call it now
i didn't didn't like my prospects there
now i'm thinking
rook um rook b7 cd4
cd4 knight c6 hope for the best
yeah bishop d5 is probably a very strong
move
uh which was not
really spotted by
the the author of the black side
this particular game
yeah rook b7 seems obvious
rook c8 or
maybe quincy eight so pretty grim
i'll go 28 make this uh
a double unintentional pull sack
because you can take and take on c6 and
take an e7
i'm hoping then i will have
you know some compensation
oh this is no good this is no good that
was a bit of a gift
i have to say queen takes e4
yeah rookie one would have been the
obvious response but unfortunately for
him
the rook on beef b1 was hanging and this
means that from being
quite clearly worse i'm now clearly
better
because i have the bishop here and the
better part structure
so the only worry that i i have now
is that the position will cut
become too dryish and um
hopefully i'll uh manage to uh
yeah to pull through um
yeah exchanging queens there was not
ideal
but looks like i'm still still winning a
pawn
uh rick p1 is logical probably
d5 was better though uh because i think
i would probably have taken on d5 he
takes an a7
i'll go rook a2 and i eventually win a2
but
um probably the four against three even
with
bishops on the board would not have been
enough this is very interesting actually
um usually you have this sort of ending
um three against against three with uh
with an a pawn
uh but the the f pawns are very rarely
uh doubled uh but i do think
sometimes the double f pawns can be good
for defensive purposes
like in in a four against three
situation i think it's
it's not bad because it's very difficult
to
create a past pawn uh against a double
pawns
but in this situation it's probably
probably no good for him because as i
said the
double pawns mainly have defensive value
and in this particular case he usually
needs to create some counter play on the
on the on the king side um
in this yeah as as it's happened um
he tried to create counter play on the
king's side but
uh but i managed to win both his f pawns
and um
with two pawns up it's plain sailing and
he resigns before i win the last one
uh okay that was um you know what
maybe i could have trapped his rook
if he'd taken the pawn on e7 i clicked
on bishop f6 that was 95
though maybe take on f3 and then
bishop f6 although then d5
queenie's a6 rook b7 probably was doing
great there
what's interesting though he should have
taken the pawn because
after what happened he just had a
considerably worse position
okay